il n'y a pas de loi du silence il n'y a
que la loi et la police gendarmerie
chaque jour chaque nuit au quotidien
s'engage pour protéger et pour servir la
loi ils le font avec honneur ils le font
avec dignité
ils le font avec un total sens de
l'engagement et je vous le dis et vous
l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas de violence
dans la police il n'y a pas de racisme
policiers mais il existe il existe des
femmes des hommes qui peuvent sauter et
nous devons sur ce sujet être
particulièrement exigeant et je le suis
et je le suis monsieur le sénateur parce
que depuis 20 mois
j'ai l'honneur d'être le premier
défenseur des flics de france
j'ai l'honneur d'être ce défenseur parce
que je sais leur engagement je sais leur
engagement quotidien permanent je sais
leur sens de l'éthique collectif et
c'est parce que je suis le premier
défenseur des flics de france que je
porte monsieur le sénateur cette
exigence d'exemplarité
parce que quand on porte l'uniforme on
porte une parcelle de la république et
canton porte cette parcelle de répliques
on se doit d'être exemplaire
on se doit d'agir dans les tic et c'est
pour cela que j'ai rappelé un certain
nombre de règles
lundi tout en réaffirmant mon engagement
à leurs côtés
j'ai rappelé des règles qui sont des
règles essentielles sur tous ces sujets
rappelé monsieur le sénateur les règles
qui doivent prévaloir lors des contrôles
d'identité j'ai rappelé monsieur le
sénateur l'exigence aussi que nous
devons comme mener pour combattre tout
acte de racisme et je les dis chaque
soupçon
chaque fait dès lors qu'une enquête
établi qu'ils sont avérées doit faire
l'objet d'une sanction administrative
immédiate
l'année dernière 30 faits de racisme ont
été signalés à l'igpn et ont fait
l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire
huit ont été classées sans suite 22 ont
été transmis au procureur de la
république dans ce cadre là monsieur le
sénateur je souhaite que dorénavant dès
lors qu'il ya transmission aux
magistrats et qu'on a les éléments qui
caractérisent une enquête qui mérite
justement cela il y ait une suspension
une suspension administrative qui est
une mesure de protection de l'ensemble
de la police et ces mesures mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs sont fait
justement pour protéger l'honneur de
policier l'honneur de nogent dame et je
sais qu'ils sont pleinement engagés en
cela